we welcome you back to cbs morning's
wnba star brittany griner is back in a
russian courtroom this morning you know
she's been in jail in russia since
mid-february on drug charges greiner
pleaded guilty earlier this month but
she says she had no intent to break the
law when she accidentally packed two
vape cartridges just before a flight
roxanna siberia is following the story
from london roxanna good morning
good morning gail griner is expected to
testify today and possibly be
cross-examined on why she brought vape
cartridges containing cannabis oil to
russia yesterday her defense team argued
she had been prescribed medical
marijuana to treat pain from injuries
standing in a metal cage as is standard
in russian courtrooms griner held up
photos of loved ones when asked if she
had any complaints she said no just
waiting patiently the two-time olympic
gold medalist has been detained since
february after she flew to moscow to
play in a russian team during the wnba
off-season the u.s says she's wrongfully
detained an accusation russia denies
greiner faces up to 10 years in prison
if convicted it's unclear how long the
trial will last but a court has
authorized her detention until
mid-december gail
well we all just want britney back home
thank you very much roxanna suberi
reporting from london